ring the alarm Beyonce's finally debut  the first photo of the Carter twins it's  officially been one month since queen  bee and jay-z welcomed their second and  third child in June B took to Instagram  Thursday night blessing her followers  with the first pick of the family's  newest addition here's the formation  singer looking regal as ever  sweetly holding sir and roomie Carter as  they appear to slumber she posed in  front of a floral setup that looks very  similar to her bombshell pregnancy  announcement as isolation meanwhile B's  snapback game is superior we can't help  but notice her incredible post-baby body  as she shows off Blue Ivy's adorable  little siblings I wanted it to be  something iconic and something that  people will never forget  you